هجوم يمني جديد على مدمره امريكيه في
البحر الاحمر هل هو انتقام ومدمره ايرانيه
تتجه للبحر الاحمر بينما تنسحب حامله
طائرات امريكيه ما الذي يجري بعد انسحاب
عبري من القطاع الجيش يبرر وواشنطن توضح
وزير الامن القومي العبري ياتي بالحل
للقطاع 14 بلده عبريه تطالب بالاجراء
والتعويض في حدود لبنان فيما خرجت دعوات
من الداخل العبري باعاده احتلال لبنان خوف
عبري من طلب تقدمت به جنوب افريقيا خطه
امريكيه لمهاجمه الحوثيين في اليمن وزعيم
كوريا الشماليه يوجه تحذيرا شديد اللهجه
لواشنطن زيلينسكي يضع الاوكران امام
خيارين وبوتين يصرح اوكرانيا ليست عدوا
لنا معارك المدمرات
مع ارتفاع حده التوترات في البحر الاحمر
وتصاعد وتيره الاشتباكات البحريه قالت
صحيفه معاريف العبريه ان الحوثيين هاجموا
سفينه حربيه امريكيه بالبحر الاحمر مشيره
الى تبادل كثيف لاطلاق النار جاء ذلك غداه
عمليه امريكيه ادت الى مقتل عشره من
البحريه اليمنيه وتدمير ثلاثه زوارق اطلقت
النار على سفينه حاويات وطائرات مروحيه
امريكيه غربيه الحديده هنا وعلى عكس
المتوقع افادت قناه اي بي سي الامريكيه في
وقت سابق بان حامله الطائره الامريكيه
جيرالد فورد تغادر منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ورجح المصدر ان تكون مغادره القطعه
البحريه الح يه الاكبر في العالم تعبيرا
عن الاستياء الامريكي من حكومه النتنياهو
واوضح مسؤولون امريكيون ان الحامله فورد
ستعود مع جميع السفن الهجوميه المرافقه
الى ميناء نورفولك فيرجينيا واليكم المصدر
نقلت شبكه اي بي سي الاخباريه عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان البنتاجون امر حامله الطائرات
يو اس اس فورد بالعوده من شرق المتوسط
بالمقابل كانت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه قد
افادت بان المدمره الايرانيه القتاليه
البار عبرت مضيق باب المندب ودخلت باتجاه
البحر الاحمر واضافت المصادر ان سفينه
بوشار العسكريه ترافق المدمره للتمركز قرب
المضيق والمدمره البرز مزوده بصواريخ كروز
بحريه بعيده المدى وها هو المصدر يتحدد
افدت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه بان المدمره
الايرانيه القتاليه البرز عبرت مضق باب
المندب ودخلت باتجاه البحر الاحمر هذا
وكانت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه قد
افادت بان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
البنتاجون اعدت خططا لمهاجمه قواعد
الحوثيين في اليمن واشارت الى انه لا يزال
هناك قلق من مثل هذه الهجمات ستصب في
مصلحه ايران وخطتها لننتقل الى معارك
القطاع حيث كان مسؤول امريكي كبير قال
لشبكه سي ان ان ان اعلان تلبيب عن بدء سحب
قواتها من القطاع يظهر مؤشرات على تحول
البلاد التدريجي الى مرحله اقل كثافه في
حربها فيما كان الجيش العبري قال في وقت
سابق انه بدا في خفض عدد جنوده على الارض
في القطاع بينما يستعد لقتال طويل الامد
طوال عام
2024 اما وسائل اعلام عبريه فاكد ان الجيش
معني بالتحرك من داخل الاراضي العبريه نحو
اهدافه وليس من داخل القطاع بينما وصف
رئيس بلديه سيدي رات العبريه الون دافيدي
خطه الحكومه في طلبها من السكان العوده
مقابل منحه ماليه بالخطه الوهميه والغبيه
مؤكدا ان الحكومه والجيش لا يتكلمان
بشفافيه ميدانيا قال الجيش العبري ان تس 2
من قتله من الضباط والجنود سقطوا بنيران
زملائهم او في حوادث عملياته منذ بدء
العمليه البريه في القطاع يوم الس7 من
اكتوبر وفق صحيفتها ارتز فيما افادت اذاعه
الجيش الامري بان الفصائل اطلقت ليلا 27
صاروخا باتجاه الكيان 13 منها اطلق من
منطقه شمالي القطاع كان الجيش قد اعلن
سابقا السيطره عليها من جهتها قالت
التايمز اوف اسرائيل ان انظمه الدفاع
الجوي العمري اعترضت 18 صاروخا في ما سقطت
تسعه منها في مناطق مفتوحه صحيفتها ارتس
عادت واكدت ان هناك خشيه لدى الجيش العبري
ومكتب المدعي العام ان تنسب محكمه العدل
الدوليه ما حدث بالقطاع لتل ابيب بناء على
الطلب الذي تقدمت به جنوب افريقيا هنا اكد
وزير الامن القومي العبري اتمار بن غفير
انه يشجع على تهجير سكان القطاع الى دول
العالم واصفا اياه بالحل الصحيح والعادل
والاخلاقي والانساني لتؤكد الفصائل في
بيان لها ان تصريحات القياده العبريه عن
تهجير شعبنا من القطاع مجرد احلام يقظه لن
تجد طريقا للتنفيذ على الحدود اللبنانيه
اعلنت مقاومه لبنان استهداف موقع حدب
البستان العبري بالاسلحه المناسبه وتحقيق
اصابات مباشره فيه ليدعو افيك دور ليبرم
رئيس حزب اسرائيل بيتون خلال اجتماع كتلته
البرلمانيه جيش بلاده الى اعاده احتلال
الاراضي الواقعه بجنوب لبنان التي انسحب
منها عام 2000 وفق ما نقلت صحيفه معاريف
العبريه فيما تقدمت 14 بلده عبريه على
حدود مع لبنان بالتماس الى المحكمه العليا
اعلى هيئه قضائيه تطالب باخلاقها وتعويضها
عن الاضرار التي لحقت بها منذ اندلاع
الحرب بحسب صحيفتها ارتس في الشرق الاسيوي
اعلن زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ اون ان
بلاده ستواجه دون تردد ضربه ساحقه تدمر
عواصم العدو اذا اختارت الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه طريق المواجهه العسكريه
ضد كوريا
الشماليه كياف بين
خيارين الضغط يولد الانفجار واوكرانيا
اصبحت بين نارين ضغط عربي للانتصار وضغط
روسي بالقوه العسكريه ليعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي في كلمته
بمناسبه راس السنه انه يتعين على كل
اوكراني عاجلا ام اجلا الاختيار بين وضع
اللاجئ والوفاء بواجبه تجاه البلاد في وقت
سابق صرح وزير الدفاع الاوكراني روستوم
عمروف بانه يواد تعبئه المواطنين الذين
غادروا البلاد فيما ذكرت صحيفه جلوبال
تايمز ان خطه الولايات المتحده لاضعاف
روسيا من خلال الازمه الاكرانيه باءت
بالفشل ويبقى نظام كياف الخسر الاكبر في
الصراع باكمله من جهته اكد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان اوكرانيا ليست عدوا
مشيرا الى ان الاعضاء هم من يريدون الحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا ليفيد المستشار
السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه دوجلاس
ماكريغور بان الولايات المتحده تتدخل في
صراعات دول اخرى دون ان تدرك ان التهديد
الامني الحقيقيه ياتي من الداخل مضيفا ان
اوكرانيا ماتت نتيجه الصراع مع روسيا الذي
اثاره حلف النيتو والولايات المتحده وها
نحن نتصفح المصدر
[موسيقى]
امامكم على الارض الاوكرانيه اكدت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان جميع المتورطين في
الهجوم على جمهوريه دونيسك سيواجهون عقابا
لا مفر منه واضافت الوزاره الروسيه ان
قواتها كانت استهدفت باسلحه عاليه الدقه
تطلق من الجو مرافق البنيه التحتيه
للمطارات الاوكرانيه التي تمركزت فيها
طائرات حامله الصواريخ ستورم شادو المجنحه
وبشان خسائر الجيش الاوكراني اليومي اظهر
تقرير الدفاع الروسيه انها بلغت نحو
685 جنديا على مختلف محاور
القتال
[موسيقى]
دخل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
c
ه